hey there and welcome to this pro flows
plus quick tip i am
cameron and in this example we're going
to look at making some
fake 3d so i'm sure most of you know how
to do
3d to extrude type inside of after
effects if you don't know how to
definitely hit me up and i'll make a
video about that
but here we go we've got a red solid
background
we've got a texture that i dropped in
it's set
to soft light so it just gives a little
bit of texture
here in the background so this is with
and without
the texture just really adds a little
bit of oomph to that background to make
it a little bit more interesting
so here is our typography and it's a
little bit like an off
off-white little yellowish tent we're
gonna go to layer
and we're gonna go to create create
shapes from text
when we do that it immediately turns off
our initial
layer which i'm gonna drag to the top
here here's our initial type layer
here is our outlines shape layer
of our text okay so what we're going to
do is we're going to go to add
and we're going to say let's make a
repeater
okay it immediately looks really strange
but watch what happens here we're going
to change the number of copies
to 17 we're going to
offset these by well let's
try negative 1 and 1.
and that seems to work let's change the
color of these so we can see them just a
little bit better
let's select that red color click ok and
let's turn on our layer above
and let's also go up here to
effect and let's do perspective drop
shadow
so i wanted to do a red on red extrusion
and that's why it looks this way now i
could change
the angle of the shadow so maybe
something like 220
maybe increase the distance a little bit
so it's a little bit off the page there
maybe increase the opacity just a hair
so you can see it's a really nice
extrusion there i can always go in i
could you know change the
fill color here to something like blue
which you know i don't love but there
you can really see the extrusion
i really like it in that red this is a
very simple way
using a shape repeater to make an
extrusion
a faux extrusion 3d extrusion on
typography
hopefully you learned something new in
this video if you did i would invite you
to check out proflos plus
over at motionscience.tv where you can
learn all about techniques trends and
methods
just like this every single month